you know a lot of times people ask me a
question they say pal what's your
favorite product in the world and the
answer has always been the same my
favorite product in the world is people
I can't get enough of people I want to
know your birthday I want to know how
you met your girl I don't wonder how we
met your boyfriend I won't know about
your parents who are you closer to mom
or dad how was it growing up who were
you in high school I want to know I'm
curious because I love people and so
this leads me into a story I want to
tell you I remember being in India we're
a Mumbai Mari and I are going and the
driver is taking us were in an Audi and
we're going in this road and then we hit
a light and it's traffic and this kid is
by the window in the car
Traver says don't open the window don't
open the window why not we're going out
the block he's following us another
block he's following us now the light
he's following us the kid is not
stopping I'm looking at this kid is
maybe six years I got a six-year-old son
I think about myself at six years old in
Iran and I'm looking at this kid say my
gosh look at this kid what does he want
he says he just wants food but don't
open the window
he's got foam next to his ear mouth why
he's on drugs don't touch him because
something could happen with you I said
kids guys he says you want me to feed
him something says yes you got to eat
something
we stopped by McDonald's and eat
something there and we go up I asked
myself okay what is the difference
between this kid isn't kidding me am i
that's special and smart and my dad
unique of a human being maybe he's got
the same level of potential as me maybe
more how come he's over there maybe
because he grew up in slums maybe
because he didn't have the same exact
opportunities what does this mean to you
we go to Argentina inflation 30% economy
scary
everybody in Argentina's telling me how
scared they are they don't know what
they're gonna do tomorrow people are
living together
you're 13 million people that could be
working are not working we go to Greece
the country is bankrupt they're going
through mess they won Europe to bail
them out they want America to bail them
out and they don't know how to handle
their finances and they think the
solution is raising taxes and these
people are men I want to start a
business and I watch these videos on
YouTube and I want to be somebody and I
tell myself how can I give me the same
opportunities I have in America how can
I give it to him I'm in a system that's
capitalism I am in America it's
capitalism it breeds entrepreneurs he's
not in that system so what do we do with
that person right there so you're
watching this right now st. Pat what's
your point
whether you're young old old
or whatever it is you're in school
you're not in school I want you to
internalize what I'm about to talk about
with you because there's two solutions
you have one has come to America the
other one is making sure you take every
single spirit of capitalism and spread
it to everybody in your country and the
only way this thing changes is by the
younger generation doing something about
it that means you so today I'm gonna
give you ten different reasons why love
capitalism
why can change your life so first of all
before I get into telling you all these
great things about capitalism I want you
to know that it is very naive to think
that any system is perfect I think a lot
of times when people want to bash
something they're expecting a hundred
percent of people to do it right for
example there's a lot of bad teachers in
the world a lot of bad parents that's
CEOs bad bosses
bad journalists bad bloggers bad YouTube
channels there's a lot of anything
that's bad that they abuse the power
they're also bad capitalists but all of
these guys give an opportunity for
somebody who's a good parent good CEO
good boss good capitalist good
journalists to become a hero where
somebody says oh my gosh look at the way
this guy does it so I'm not here to be
naive and tell you all the great things
about capitalism because I read all the
negative stuff about capitalism here's
an article top 10 reasons why capitalism
sucks people are unhappy competition
destruction adverse selection
you know externalities monopolies you
know free riding pointless cause under
consumption you know in humanity
inequality which by the monopolies don't
exist without the help of government the
only way a monopoly can happen is with
the help of a government this is where
you see crony capitalism taking place
I'm simply talking about a system on
what a system does so here's what I want
you to be thinking about let's talk
about some of the capitalists that they
don't care about you know the
environment they don't care about what
the world looks like we're specifically
talking about environment on point
number one say they don't care it's like
listen I just want to make money man
forget about it I don't care if this
solar is gonna be dirty I don't give
this guys got all this smog because our
cars barely pass us mocked us I don't
care about that you know what that's
perfect that's perfect because it opens
up the opportunity for a young
guy that's watching us in oh my gosh you
know what what if we created cars that
were driven by batteries and I could put
charges all over the country all over
the world and you just go would go to
charge your battery for like two hours
and you go charge about it for two 20
minutes and you go for another
tournament what if I could do that and
that guy's name is Elon Musk and then he
becomes a hero and he creates Tesla and
people who own Tesla's they swear by
Tesla's people in Tesla's I've never
owned a Tesla before every friend that I
have who owns a Tesla it's like you're
part of a cult because they feel good
that they're making the world a cleaner
place right now what am I saying about
this a capitalist that didn't care about
the environment gave birth to Elon Musk
let me give you a different perspective
here environment I want you to watch
this commercial here it's a two-minute
commercial Mario let's put the link
below if somebody wants to watch the
whole commercial but I'm just gonna give
you 30 seconds everything we're gonna
play a game I want you to guess which
company's commercial this is watch it
and tell yourself I think it's such an
such company watch as commercial when we
look across the globe we have growing
populations this really puts a lot of
pressure and an increased demand on
water supplies that's why we're intently
focused on being good water stewards we
do that through a wide variety of
projects most of them around
restoring a protecting watersheds or
water resources
maybe it's connecting flood plains to
streams they might be working with
farmers or growers who implement better
irrigation best management practices
it's a night and day difference between
the before picture in the after picture
we're really spreading new messages
about what sustainability looks like not
just for today but even 20 years from
now
for those to me that had never seen this
commercial before in your wildest dreams
did you think that was gonna be a
coca-cola commercial be honest be honest
coca-cola commercial I'll keep this in
mind Coca Cola's gotten a lot of heat
coke I write a lot of heat over the
years in Iran in the world everywhere a
lot of heat you know what they realize
they better change it up they better
start worrying about water you know why
because if all this water supply goes
through they're out of business they
better pay attention to the water supply
in the world they better pay attention
to water being cleaned they better
invest billions of dollars of research
to make sure waters gonna be okay
because without it coca-cola doesn't
exist what does that tell you capitalism
becomes a business that you have to pay
attention to the environment or else the
capitalist running the business will be
extinct number two here's the next great
thing about capitalism your vote
actually matters you know a lot of
countries you live in or States you live
in in America there are some states that
whether you vote or not it's gonna be
Republican or it's gonna be Democrat
your vote doesn't matter in a lot of
different places states like California
or New York your vote doesn't really
matter a lot Illinois your vote doesn't
really matter a lot right so a lot of
times that builds my vote really matter
when it comes to business it does here's
why there is no place to go complain
about a government official look there's
not a Yelp for government officials
there's not a Yelp for presidents
there's not a Yelp for DMVs no DMV cares
if you want to go out there and say bad
things about them businesses complete
different story people were unhappy with
uber you know what happens the following
month
all the people that will use an uber
everybody want to lift cuz that's how we
vote you're not happy with Starbucks
coffee bean I am NOT happy with
McDonald's Burger King I am NOT happy
with a gym
Bally's used to be all over the place
gone LA Fitness 24-hour Fitness your
vote matters and businesses no and the
reason the reason that they know how
much your vote matters they have to
treat you better because if they don't
you may be voting for somebody else
very soon number three you know I'm
always curious when the person that
complaints about a capitalist and video
I'm making about entrepreneurship
something like that about business to
person complaints capitalism is the
worst system and they're complaining on
their iPhone or their smartphone on
YouTube all started by capitalist which
by the way this is a complete different
perspective to give you for you to be
thinking about what is innovation do for
you well how many of you today watching
this actually like what you do for a
living how many you love your jobs do
you love what you do
by the way would you replace doing what
you do right now versus I don't know
being a farmer would you want to be a
farmer would you want to work on a farm
let me explain to you what the
conditions of a farmer is mosquito bites
all day right spiders you're working
with dirt they're sweating son maybe
rain you got to work you know you got to
go through it now you've got to be
working 12-hour days it's a lot of
manual labor would you want to be a
farmer would you want to be a farmer
would you if you said no for some of you
that are watching st. Pat I don't get
the points here this pad want us to go
back to being farmers and working in
agriculture here's what I'm saying to
you in America during colonial times 90%
of all workers in America worked in
agriculture everybody was a farmer
everybody you would have been a farmer
today by the way in 1940 1% were farmers
in 1900 in America 41% of all of us we'd
be doing agriculture I wouldn't be
running an insurance company right norsu
you know doing vitamin videos I'd be if
on a farm I'm a pretty big guy I can
probably pick up a lot of strawberries
where I can probably go on working
pretty huh I'd be a farmer you'd be a
farmer dart all this stuff right outside
being around it but you're not a farmer
today today only 2% of people in America
are farmers we went from 90 percent to
41 percent to 2 percent today are you
glad are you glad are you glad that
there's not a farmer city what happened
there what happened there that's called
innovation the capitalist said we can
figure out a better way of doing this
let's get to work and because of
capitalists they figured out ways to do
it better they figured out ways to make
it more efficient and I gave you the
opportunity to have a different kind of
a job where you can work behind a desk
or whatever it is that you do out there
and you don't have to be outside 12
hours a day working hard because of a
cap
was figuring out a way to add
advancement and innovation that gave me
the opportunity to do what you do today
rather than being a farmer number four
you know here's another thing that
capitalism did capitalism took us for
the longest time wherever you live for
you know all over the world most things
that we did we were forced to do it was
forced to do a lot of things and
capitalism brought the spirit of choices
you don't have to do this you have a
choice you don't have to work here it's
a choice right you don't have to do
anything it's a choice let me give you
an example for many years in America
everybody you know if you were a certain
age and if America needed soldiers you
were forced to go into the army or the
military it was called a draft and
people hated it many of the younger
generation is not gonna know about it
when I was in the US Army
I went by a choice a lot of people would
tell me stories who were older that it
used to be by force you were drafted and
people would on flat-footed or I don't
the only child or I have health issues
all my blood type is this I don't see
very well people would make up all these
different excuses to avoid being drafted
right do you know why the draft went
away in America why do we not have a
draft in America today
well a Nobel prize-winner named Milton
Friedman who if you haven't watched any
of his videos just go on Google type in
Milton Friedman and watch every one of
his debates he's fascinating right he
said if America is about capitalism and
capitalism is about choices we should
make the same with military and get away
with draft why because if you get people
who join the army by choice you have
better soldiers then you get people who
you forced to go to war why not let
people choose to serve their country
where it matters to them then force them
to go on it's like making somebody do
something they hate the spirit of
capitalism got away with the spirit of
force and that's why there's no longer
draft in America number five so you know
how you hear this entire think about
redistribution of wealth oh my god
you know socialism sucks because you got
to redistribute wealth here's why it
sucks it sucks because it forces you to
redistribute your wealth
unlike capitalism let me explain
Bezos was recently interviewed and they
asked him they said hey how do you feel
about the fact that you worth a hundred
and sixty billion dollars he says I
don't feel bad about it because the
company's worth one trillion and I'm
worth 160 that means I have
redistributed wealth to other people and
made them eight hundred and forty
billion dollars let me say this one more
time a company Amazon goes from zero two
trillion he is worth 160 he gave 84% of
the company to other people redistribute
by choice and effort and results eight
hundred and forty billion dollars of
wealth is spread amongst other people
that brought value or invested into
Amazon now that is my kind of
redistribution of wealth because it's by
choice not by force number six so
remember the whole concept of capitalism
is a lot of different spirits another
spirit about capitalism is the fact that
you have to improve if you don't improve
you're gonna take a hit and this happens
all the time in business but it also
happens all the time in life how many
times have you met somebody that doesn't
take care of their health they
McDonald's three times a day they go eat
fast food all the time they eat
cheesecake Swedes coke all the sub they
smoke they drink and they just look
unhealthy right and people are surprised
I can leave this guy died at 49 years
old I can't believe this person died at
52 now look at this other person they
live 93 years old in 99 years old in 91
years old and for some of you that
always look for the anomaly well I know
my grandpa that smoked for 58 years and
is 92 still alive remember I'm not
talking about a hundred percent I'm
talking majority I'm not looking for a
perfect formula the point I'm trying to
make you is the following
those who focus on improving lasts a
long time
business is the same way if you don't
improve your business and your name is
Sears you could potentially be put out
of business by a guy named Amazon ran by
Jeff Bezos who constantly is focused on
improving by the way here's the part
that everybody has to realize there was
a time that people said Sears will never
follow bankruptcy they overcame a world
war one or two a Great Depression what
you mean to tell me they cannot make it
through this thing that Amazon's giving
them all this
competition yes today no one in the
world thinks Apple would ever go out of
business no one thinks today that Jeff
Bezos Amazon will ever file bankruptcy
do you think that do you think they'll
ever do that think about it no one
thinks about that right but that's today
if Jeff Bezos all of a sudden got
comfortable together replaces him does
fast-forward 10 20 30 40 50 years from
that a new company may come out that is
more focused on improving and making it
better for you that puts them out of
business this whole concept here is why
prices went from being expensive to
being cheap because somebody looks at
and says that's too expensive of a car
that's too expensive for a book that's
too expensive for food that's too
expensive for this I don't like the way
they're doing a fast food day that's not
healthy this is not good and somebody
else who is saying if you look at the
people in the marketplace they're
looking for healthier if you look at the
marketplace and you listen they want
speed if you listen to the marketplace
customer service is very high people
want you to pay attention to social
issues why don't we do that and we
improve and we'll get into customers
those who improve will last those who
don't will eventually die number seven
so I want you to look at the list of
Fortune 500 companies all these big
companies right go on fortune 500 the
names and here's what I want you to
search I want you to find a company that
is a fortune 500 company with one
employee how many you think you'll find
how about with 50 employees you're not
gonna find it it's a lot of employees
you know why the beautiful thing about
capitalism is the capitalist starting
the company needs it needs people they
need people you see when I was working
on valleys and I came out of the
military I hadn't no idea what it is to
work in a sales environment had never
worked before in sales ever I was always
like this you know I sold hats and all
this other stuff but not an organized
people come to me and all this other
stuff I worked at Bob's Big Boy I worked
at Burger King I worked at haciendas and
it was in a military that was pretty
much it I got into sales and I noticed
oh my gosh I got quit that guy got fired
that guy did this and this guy did this
I said I'm gonna learn sales so much and
mastered the scripts on phone calls on
guests coming in on the walkins on
telephone inquires on going and shaking
hands with all the members there working
out I would literally walk around
Bally's and I would see somebody neither
said hey Jon you neither said yes
how's your work Yemen how's it been you
looking good everything the family good
anyone your friends remember anybody
wants a membership you can come and talk
and here's my card
hey Larry you need a spot let me here
let me put your eyes put my arm here put
your feet here let's do the pull-ups you
got it two more come on buddy let's go I
went through it and all of a sudden I'm
like wait a minute these guys need me I
got promoted can you go to the bigger
Club can you do this can you do that
that same principle was applied because
people need people like that all
corporations out there need talent like
this there's this notion about saying
that well you know companies don't treat
their people right and they don't do all
this other stuff yes there are those
companies but at the same time I also
know a lot of people who have jobs who
are entitled who kind of feel like what
they got to do everything for me yet
they don't give that additional part
that's why bad employees there are
plenty of bad employees just like
there's plenty of bad capitalist bad
employees allowed the good employees who
go above and beyond everybody else to
constantly rise up and eventually if
that's not gonna work out in the company
you're with I guarantee you someone's
gonna need you number eight so I got a
question for you how long would you like
to live honestly how long would you like
to live what's your number like in your
mind what do you say you say I wanna
live 80 years you know I'd love to live
100 years what is that age what do you
think about how long would you like to
live and by the way why are you not even
thinking about the fact that maybe you
only have two or three years left to
live what do you mean Pat let me tell
what I mean by this
1,900 the average life expectancy of a
citizen of the world somebody in the
world average you know how old the age
was 31 1990 years ago was 31 think about
that right there by the way in 1950 48
you know what it is today
Oh world this is not America world today
72 years old we went from 31 to 72 years
old you mean to tell me in a hundred and
twenty years my life expectancy
increased by 41 years are you serious
yes so the question becomes this why why
why are we living longer is it because
global warming makes us live longer
is it because all of a sudden the trees
are better trees or is the oxygen we
breed betters the water that much better
no it's called advancement and
capitalism medicine gets better we live
longer ken Langone one of the founders
of Home Depot wrote a books that I love
capitalism he's 80 to 83 years old his
father I believe died in his early 60s
you know what he said he said my dad
died in his early 60s at a young age you
know why because back then we didn't
have blood thinners ken has been on
blood thinners for a while because he's
on blood thinners he hasn't had a heart
attack he's 83 years old he's still
living still he's on the knew but if you
look at him you tell yourself this man
is probably gonna go for another 20
years
why advancement so the reason why you
and I are living longer today is because
somebody who is a capitalist use their
capital to advance medicine which is why
you and I live longer today number 9 you
know if you speak to any parent and you
tell them listen what do you want your
kid to do when they grow up most parents
will say I just won't like you to be
happy I want them to be happy I want her
to be happy matter of fact don't you
want to be happy are you happy you are
you happy doing what you're doing today
you may say yes I am happy but happy too
you may be different than happy it is to
me may be happy to you is working 9:00
to 5:00 Monday through Friday taking
Friday afternoon off to golf and you
have Saturdays and Sundays off because
that's what happy means to you happy to
me that's miserable to me right I may
say happy to me is running and gun and
working 80 hours a week building
something that's never been done before
spreading a message that's gonna change
the entire world that's happy to me
somebody may say Pat you're absolutely
miserable who wants to work as hard as
you do
somebody else may say happy to me is
working for a non-profit you have no
idea how happy I am we're gonna
contribute to different areas every time
there's a crisis all over the world I go
and I contribute the other day there was
a flood I was in Puerto Rico I went to
Panama City I wanted to contribute on
when the earthquake happened that's
happy to me
I only make 32 grandeur but I'm happy
here's a point there isn't only one kind
of happy everybody has a different kind
of happy the problem is sometimes
everybody's imposing their happiness on
your like for you to be happy like me
you have to be doing exactly what I'm
doing for you to be happy that's not
true there's different types of
happiness right I'll give you an example
add a friend here's a number-one
backgammon player in the world Viktor
Ashkenazi okay he originally was born
and raised in Russia lived it for
20-some years under communist Ignatian
went to st. Peter's but came to America
went to NYU
after NY you worked at Soundgarden goes
to goldman sachs for 11 years today he's
a grandmaster back down and play the
best one in the world today and we start
talking and one of the things that would
came up was a story about a lady who
would pick out my outfits at Nordstrom's
and I would go buy it from her right and
she was a person I was from Russia and
she left Russia because she had a son
and she didn't think her son had the
same opportunity in Russia as she would
in America but she missed one thing
about communism I said what is it she
would say Pat I miss the fact that after
work everybody would get home at 4 or 5
o'clock and just play cards we play
games we'd have drinks we laugh we play
music nobody worked there was no
competition it was like everybody was
just hanging out there was none of this
ego stuff we were just together was so
amazing to me right now watch this
I said that's amazing very good point by
the way that is an element of happy to
most people me and you included we love
our family right but the question we got
to ask is the following what different
types of happy can coexist in communism
and socialism and capitalism
what do you mean Pat watch this Elon
Musk what is happy to him Elon Musk is
start a business on the moon right if
you think about how Elon Musk is wired
do you think Elon Musk in a communistic
nation would be happy do you think he'll
are musk in a socialistic nation like
Greece would be happy were all this
regulations there I don't know if you
would be happy now watch this other
person America the person America works
for a nonprofit organization do you
think she or he can coexist in communism
that they're giving back probably she
can't coexist there do you think the
person that's an executive here they
don't want to be an Elon Musk but they
want to work 60 hours a week and I want
to make a half a million dollar your
income live in a good community they
don't want to be celebrities they're
low-key people but they want to make a
half a million can that person coexist
in Russia or in Greece they can't
coexist in those places see what
capitalism allow us to do is it allows
multiple different types of happiness to
coexist because Elon Musk can't live in
America that non profit person can the
one that wants to be an executive can
and a person that just wants to work
9:00 to 5:00 and get Friday afternoons
off
can co-exist in capitalism this is why
capitalism system allows all kinds of
happy to just mesh and live together
number 10 I want you to think about that
relative that you have that judges you
all the time every time you do something
they judge you I can't believe you just
did this look what you're doing how dare
you do that shame on you shame on you
how do we feel when somebody judges us
all the time right we can't stand it you
don't like it I can nobody likes it
right you know it's a great thing about
capitalism you know it's one of the
great things about capitalism it
forgives you it's very forgiving and by
the way it's got a memory like very
quickly capital sim gets over your old
mistakes what do I mean by this see you
see a lot of people at the top that they
make it but you only see their final
product you don't see what mistakes they
made if I had to make my list my list is
a very very long this matter of fact I
even made a video about it calls twelve
mistakes I made as an entrepreneur
what's the point here you screwed up you
build a business they don't work out you
made a bad decision financially you lost
everything you can go work another job
save your money three years later start
a business and come back up and by the
way you can fill once twice three times
four times five times if you only think
anybody matters the only thing anybody
cares about is your last victory because
you win one time everybody forgets all
the past mistakes you made
so what capitalism is forgiveness are
you watching this right now saying oh my
god
I just felt last year I made a big
mistake two years ago Capleton forgives
you so those are the ten reason why life
capitals my motto I'm on pull of
capitals and move on you right now I
must sell you shirt here's what I'm
selling you this should right here enjoy
capitals and maybe like this one or this
one or this one maybe this one maybe
this one here whichever one you like if
you want to sport capitalism and
entrepreneurship get one of these shirts
put them on anywhere you go when people
see it there's a reaction the link will
be below for you to go out and purchase
this shirt any one of them by the way if
you're watching this video game pad I
want more information three years ago we
bought an RV six of us lived in an RV we
went from LA to Miami to Toronto to San
Fran back to land I give speeches all
over the plate thousands of people
showed up and the speech was titled DNA
of an entrepreneur if you haven't
watched the speech here's a highlight of
this speech DNA of an entrepreneur one
of my favorite speeches I've ever given
you gotta watch it it'll go little
deeper about the topic we discussed in
this video take everybody love you bye
bye